oh i'm hype dog are you i'm hype
oh he hyped he hi hi he hi why are you
high
dude i'm hype because we have a new
opportunity
a new option really people say we'll do
two episodes a week do an extra
how long them knuckleheads been asking
oh give us another bonus episode give us
behind the scenes footage
oh give us exclusive merch oh daddy oh
daddy yeah people say my cousin died let
me get an extra episode
i know i said look i'm i'll do what i
can and that's why what we have now
is the new cat's patreon i'm so excited
about it why don't you hit him with the
tears daddy
oh well don't touch me go ahead and get
that bonus episode every month
plus patreon members can make
submissions of their own
make sure it gets in the episode
streamline that and we also got that
second tier that
keep touching but don't stop you get
everything in the first tier
plus you get all the regular episodes ad
free
yup add free versions of the regular
episodes then finally we got that
premier tier
that meet me at 20. what's up dog
everything in the first two tiers i just
told your ass about
plus you get the exclusive 360 camera
what like avatar 7 up in this [ __ ]
pre-show behind the scenes exclusive
merch items just for the patreons
plus monthly q and a access you don't
know who you get you can get the king
sting
you get the rat king we did that
backwards you can get chappelle
you can get freaking cat's feet you get
chins beard
i don't know you get nick talking to
whoever yep
uh after the episode then we'll have
somebody sit in and do a q a
um and all the options are available on
patreon.com
king and the sting uh so you guys check
it out
uh it's just for for people that want
that extra episode that want extra
uh cats you know it's gonna be awesome
we're excited about it and it will not
affect any of the regular episodes
um everything else uh where you're
getting this now will be exactly the
same it's just on top of it yeah
for the true king of the sting fans
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch
[Music]
half of me digs this half of me
[Laughter]
i respect it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
such a yeah song
how where is it they still got a queen
this is the british national anthem
yes sir god save the queen yes sir now
it really has
a lot of the same stuff as uh the same
pentameter or whatever is your thing as
uh
national anthem yeah i mean we basically
you know stole their [ __ ]
wow well we used to be them so yeah
exactly so we're just like yeah
it's kind of like music these days yeah
culture vulture
yep britain man that's how we got here
crazily i mean we didn't really you did
happy
i didn't did half of me came here so you
were born and raised over there
wow your mom has an accent she did when
it growing up she did it's gone away my
aunt does
my grandma did oh rest in peace yeah
what part are they from stroud australia
where is that
is that near manchester no all right and
what is it it's more
south it's a little this little town
south get some images of stroud can you
nick images of stroud rural strata dude
i grew up on wine gums
tea what you know about wine gums you
look like you smuggle wine gums in your
butt
that's what you look like you don't you
know what wine gums are no
no i don't the best candy on planet
earth oh yeah see i'm not a big daddy
fan
oh [ __ ] yeah england was the best candy
yeah
don't you know chappelle here's what you
here's how it works mr bell you say
something he's like i don't know what
you're talking about
you're right yeah i keep going back to
the well don't i yeah
the well of unknown over there and it's
horrible because it's you
yeah since it's you you don't say
nowhere it's you saying the ideas too
so they're out of the gate they are very
suspect suggestions then wine gums
oh just oh gummy's my favorite now that
stroud right there yep
i mean that's your home they're not uh
gummy bears how dare you
i'll bring some in for you okay and look
we want to just say thank you to
everybody from britain man
and everybody that's you know british
yeah shout out to oasis
yup shout out to winston churchill
shout out to elton john elton john game
of thrones game of thrones
david beckham jen name somebody
name and asian british
yeah the one that's on so many asian men
the screen saver is he british
no he's not going to be asian austin
powell
powers let's talk about tyson fury
michael bisping
anthony joshua darren till anthony
joshua
um who else who's a famous soccer player
that's british
oh god they got a ton why i already said
david beckham david beckham
um what's something else that's british
pork and beans is british spice girls
spices oh
good one you know they one direction
wow that's a good one name something
british dude fish and
chips dog fish and chippies prince harry
crisp would you say chin prince harry
prince harry
he's out bro he moved bro he's out of
the royal family
he got a girl and she's like i don't
like them he's like yeah [ __ ] them and
they move
princess diana this is diana who i
actually
i didn't know i was at my buddy's house
and he's homosexual where he was he died
yeah but he uh
and he was making us some dinner okay
and he's like princess diana died the
news came on
and he started crying i knew who
princess anna was you know i knew it was
like a beanie baby or something that's
all i knew about it
you talking about that purple beanie
baby tough to get yeah
and uh there's a beanie baby ever there
was there was
but um anyway my mama went to
deep depression when she passed away a
lot of people it was a tough
round-the-shop household when princess
diana died
because your mother grew up in stroud
brother yes she was sad did your mother
sound british
oh yeah wow my aunt sue has a thick
accent
aunt nubby gots an accent dude have them
[ __ ] send in a video
that's right huh you don't want to hang
out with me shut up huh
brandon we would love that wouldn't we
my mom would love it yeah i should have
dude yeah we would love to hear from
those ladies wouldn't we nick yes we
would
yes we would nick sounds like he's
like he's been like kidnapped yeah yes
i wasn't sure what
oh we got a guest on that's true man
we're coming right out of uh out of the
uk
and let's let's premier league soccer
what you know about you guys don't know
[ __ ] about christian pulsic
the number one american player over
there doing the goddamn thing dang
the best american player ever really for
chelsea son
respect 21 year old dude out of
pennsylvania what about the
revolutionary
war that we won sure are we honoring are
we making fun of them
not bad but here's what the episode
in their face doug yeah we want to say
we might be coming back over there
um because things are getting a little
rocky here in the states
and so we wanted to talk to uh to a
prideful member of the uk
and just let him know that we might be
on our way back over there and see what
he has to say you might go back to the
old routes
yep have you have you been to your home
yeah first time i went there was last
year i toured there for comedy
i've never been my whole family's been
i've never been first time there touring
comedy
oh gosh i gotta go there so we wanted to
uh
we wanted to go and just have a guest
from the uk that we could talk to he's
fresh off his first ufc bout and
uh and it was a win and we got jack
shore
entering right here probably wouldn't
have him on if he lost let's be real
about it
okay
and he's also a massive king in the
sting fan yeah that's true he loves the
show
let's see if we can get him i think
jack can you hear us yeah
what's up man what's going on not much
dude just want to say congrats on your
win man
and uh and just let you know we're doing
an episode that's all british
and um and we just wanted to talk to
somebody from britain and see how it's
going over there
yeah well i appreciate the the thanks on
the win britain's a bit uh but crazy at
the minute we're still like
locked down big time so you know we're
uh
we come i come back from the fight
island i'm straight back from the house
so uh
i'm getting i'm getting a little bit fat
i can't get as much training as i won't
do but
oh brennan's fat
[Laughter]
i stay i stay thick man i'm just joking
he's thick my bad man
that was kind of rude my bad good steal
you know how you doing brother
i'm all good i'm all good i'm uh i'm
getting back into the uh the thick boy
status again already got my bike you
know
i was i was too skinny to uh to be
classed as a fit boy i think on a fight
night
no you're in the club bro do they give
you uh do you get tickets out there like
we do in america like i got a ticket for
riding my bike outside when the pandemic
first hit
uh we haven't had i haven't heard enough
in you know they're not so strict i mean
there was a rule that you couldn't you
couldn't leave the house favored in sort
of
five to ten kilometers but no one really
listened i think they were
running on the bikes and [ __ ] but yeah
yeah we
i haven't had a ticket yet i mean i i'm
trying to get away from him as fast as i
can but
you know it's a little bit different
view on the trails that met i'm on the
roads a little bit so i try to
avoid the police if we can are are all
the pubs shut down there those are bars
not allowed yeah it's it's completely
shut they've opened like
outdoor areas now in the in the pubs and
the clubs but
i cut a couple of couple of landlords
and i
that i know have opened up on the sneak
and they've been shut down like real
fast so
we still uh there's no one there's no
one drinking legally at the minute over
here but there's a lot of people
drinking illegally
and do um ask him someone
are you an oasis fan yeah massive voices
that's my favorite band hey how do you
so if joshua and fury fight how do you
guys decide over there who the [ __ ] the
root for
i think it's quite 50 50. um to be
honest like
the last year with fury and he's sort of
coming back from the mental elephant
coming back from obviously he was down
and out he's just
the public loves him over here now like
going back five years ago everyone ate
the types of fury now all of a sudden
he is this this like you know the
general public to see him as this
superstar this hero so
i mean i'm team gypsy king all the way
but uh
you know joshua is people are fond of
joshua over here too so i i think it's
really going to be like a 50 50 split
but uh
i'm team gypsy kicking without a doubt
me too
and what about when you guys had that
guy that fought logan paul
what were you guys psi yeah ksi does
anybody cheer for that guy
or did did everybody think that they
were both a bunch of wankers or what was
the deal
for him now he got like get knocked
about really pretty easily but um
you know i don't even think like that
anyone took that fight seriously
[Laughter]
it's more of an american thing yeah
now the rematch was my second date with
my girlfriend or my first date with my
girlfriend i brought a staple center for
logan paul ksi oh you did yeah yeah wow
the undercard was billy joe saunders
who's english stud and like
no one gave a [ __ ] about the real fights
like in full of youtubers
yeah it was 12 year olds with their
parents it was it was hilarious and
i think he would jack would say billy
joe saunders is legit billy joe saunders
yeah he's supposed to fight canelo until
he did some stupid video
pretend to hit a woman on a bag damn
yeah billy
billy joe's um a little bit
controversial
he doesn't help himself sometimes like
like you said the video with the women
and
he's always like instagram line winding
up sorry instagram live like winding up
homeless people and
he's funny though he he's tyson fury's
best friend oh yeah
he's a character now was it pretty cool
at the yaz island or was it kind of like
scary or what was it like yeah it was
pretty cool i mean we didn't see as much
as it was
as we would have liked we was like
locked in the hotel room for you know a
couple of days and then by the time we
we had the weigh-ins and the fight i
mean i thought 4am and i was
flown back on 4pm the next day so we
didn't get to see too much of it you
know but uh
we're just just grateful to be out there
with the team and you know able to fight
and
earn some money in uh in these crazy
times was it weird fighting with no
crowd
yeah a little bit i mean it was the the
walk out and the the intros with bruce
buffer
was really weird like it seems awkward
there's like jack show and it was just
dead silence
but the fight itself wasn't too bad i
switched off on it a little bit so
you know it was just a walk out that was
a little bit weird but i want to shout
out them
i think chappelle liked it i don't know
if he's seen it but he's seen i walked
out to an oasis too
oh gang
man legit oasis dude
i gotta get out there man what am i
doing we gotta ship you over there man
yeah well look one of the things we
wanted to say jack is that we might be
coming back to uh our original homeland
to the uk because things are getting a
little bit weird over here dicey over
here
we might fire up the old mayflower and
head on back
do you think yeah what are some tips
that you could give us that's a good
question where should we go should we go
should we land in liverpool
manchester stroud you don't want to land
in liverpool trust me on that one
darren till says they have the best
nightlife in all
in all of england man odds
yeah if you like if you like fighting
and
getting pushed around a lot like they're
crazy up in liverpool yeah it's like
wisconsin huh
yeah but if you're coming to the uk stop
off in wales yeah
we're only small but then we show you a
good time we're uh
we're very welcoming down here so come
down to the to the small part and uh you
know we'll always be welcome
we pick whales over england every day
and what are some things that uh we
should know like
how to adapt into the culture there
because i mean there's a there's
probably about a 12
chance that we're actually going to come
to come and i'd say even 12 is pretty
high
there's probably a 99 chance with me
yeah so yeah
what are some what are some things we
could do especially chappelle even to
adapt into the culture
like chappelle's having heard of wine
gums
oh wine gums are the best the best horse
weigh-in treat
everyone get that sugar straight in the
system
the biggest tip man uh obviously if you
come over
don't drive on the right hand side of
the road
all right that's a good start i think
it's a good start
i didn't want to put him on the spot but
uh i asked him before the show do you
have any uh
english uh debate clubs or king or
stingers for the guys
you want to throw out to them yeah you
want to throw one out jack before we uh
before we let you go here and thanks so
much for uh for joining us this morning
man yeah no problem um
it's not so much an english one but that
i know uh
obviously brendan used to be in the ufc
and i know field's a big fan um
of dustin pouring the guys so the big
club for me would be
having fought in obviously with fans
present and then in an empty arena
would you rather the fights with the
fans or without the fans
um i don't know sometimes those fans are
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so
it's like
and they give stupid ass advice like rip
his head off
i'm [ __ ] trying he's really good dude
you know so i found the ultimate fighter
with no fans it was kind of dope less
pressure you can just do your thing
feels like practice i don't mind i like
watching without fans too so i don't
mind no fans man
yeah and i probably would get my ass
kicked in either space so
i uh i think i would say no fancy
because i don't want anybody there to
see it you know
you know i'm yelling world star
then you can hear dan hardy out the ref
with no fans that's true that's always
fun
yeah um who was the ref for your fight
jack
it was actually herb dean
he's probably not fond of us british at
the minute because of daddy
he'll be all right who do you think are
winning a fight out of herb dean and no
nonsense keith peterson
is keith peterson been drinking oh no
i'm gonna go out on a limb is keith lit
what are we doing man i'm gonna say
i'm gonna go on a limb and say yes um
yeah all day bro jack thanks so much for
uh jumping on man and we appreciate it
and uh
and we hope to see you soon in your
country we'll be showing up on the show
yeah yeah welcome anytime thanks for
having me on guys i'm a big fan
nice guy that was awesome yeah nice guy
you found a new best friend yeah i did
i thought he's just [ __ ] he came out
to an oasis song he said chappelle
how you saying see that dude sure like a
shoreline
people love you people love you in other
countries chapel i know that's actually
pretty [ __ ] cool
yeah another reason to go over there go
over there yeah
you know now you know he's on london
though right he's in wales oh you
already already follow me
go over there and sleep at his house
you can stay at his place i could fall
asleep to oasis songs
oh i do that all the time every night do
it with him
yeah i would why not
all right so there's nothing wrong with
it man it's nothing
especially i don't know if it's easier
do you think it's easy to be gay in some
countries or not
oh yeah it's much easier to be gay in
america than anywhere else
yeah you might try being gay in mexico
it doesn't go well
would you try it or something nope i
just wrote stories
dude you want some jewelry man oh you
never know you might need that
engagement ring down the road you might
need a nice
thick chain with all diamonds dazzle me
[ __ ] that's
on my neck diamond's on my chain what's
up man you need anything
fancy jewelry high-end jewelry i'm
talking about bluenow.com
original online jeweler to high-income
adults
and what i want to tell you about blue
nile is they got two types of fine
jewelry
and wedding jewelry so they got that
classy that's swaggy
you know that freaking lit grit the
stuff you want to roll into the club
with
then they got that piece you want to put
on your lady or your man
or your gay man it means forever yeah
that little slice of forever you want to
balance on the knuckles yeah dog
that's exactly what you need to do it's
time to mark a special occasion what are
you trying to do man
anniversary whatever it is maybe
celebrating getting your wig
taken off whatever it is celebrate with
some fine
jewelry yep they got diverse styles for
uh they got
modern they got classic vintage what
yeah don't settle don't stress out about
shopping for jewelry
anymore yup it's ethically sourced gia
graded diamonds in every shape and size
with an endless selection of settings to
help you design the ring of her dreams
treat your dame to that dime
that diamond rang gang do it together
man we got a special
girl with your friend yeah let's hit him
with that nice special
offer right now
100 percent satisfaction guaranteed and
we celebrate
your love mm-hmm and celebrate life's
special moment somebody won a contest
somebody
spelling bee yeah your daughter got her
first hickey you know get her that
diamond piece what's up man
go to bluenile.com and king and the
sting listeners get 50
off your first purchase over 750.
this podcast exclusive includes loose
diamonds ooh i'm trying to get that
loose diamond
that ld baby that learning disability
yeah use code kats that's code
cats plus every order is insured ships
free and arrives in discreet little
package so it doesn't give away your
surprise
shop stress free right now find your
forever piece go to bluetooth.com
today yo bro it's tough to go to the gym
right now everybody trying to work out
at home and i thought the other day man
i wish there was an app where i could
get fit okay
and then somebody went dude get fit bod
it's a smart fitness app that takes all
the guesswork out of planning your
workouts all right
each workout i know the app learns your
abilities plans your workout designs to
work out
so you get into shred city son i'm
feeling fat and sad
dude they need fit bod bro fitbod
combines the knowledge of fitness pros
with a powerful machine learning
algorithm to give you a workout program
that is the best
just for you no equipment no problem
but i'm feeling fat and sad though dude
they need that fitbot to get fit and
happy
fitbot has bodyweight routines for those
looking to get fit at home
or on the go it's super easy to use they
got videos
and guess what you can try one month of
workouts absolutely
free oh i love this man my ex-girlfriend
does this kind of stuff and she loves it
and she's getting fit man because
but not me i've been fat and sad well
let's get you happy man get personalized
fitness plan that helps you work out
smarter at fit bod dot me slash kats try
fit bod
for free for one month when you sign up
today at fit bod
dot me slash kats that's one month free
when you sign up at fit bod dot me slash
cats oh if i use this then i'll just be
sad
so brendan tell us more about what you
know about your history man because i'm
curious if you're british man that's
wild that your mom and your aunts had
that accent
wow i know weird huh was it cool growing
up or was it kind of like
at that time did you think it was not
cool i thought it was normal that my
grandma my aunts
they would smoke and cuss so much so i
thought everyone was like that yeah
you know how the osbournes were remember
when the osborne's everyone's like damn
why are they cussing so much
that's just the way it was my mom just
cuts a [ __ ] ton
that's awesome still does really oh yeah
dude that's awesome man
that's so funny i didn't think about
them having british accents when i was
thinking about y'all it's just
i was like oh i didn't think they would
have british accents oh yeah
that's dope does your mom go back uh
yeah every now and then
wow yeah so you also have a lot of
family there oh yeah
oh yeah wow yeah aunts cousins did you
whenever you went over there to tour
with tfatk did you guys go now i
went by myself oh you didn't used to
stand up out there did you see any
family while you were there no
i don't think so i think they came to
the shows it was busy we
we planted two last minute sauce city to
cities oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah that's
right
i can't see anyone yeah it was dope
though damn
i'd love to go back um
i want to go back and go to a premier
league game yeah
that'd be sick well thanks for talking
to a fighter man i know it's not a fight
show but i was just trying to know i
like that crazy
noise
enthusiastic young man like he's just
those kids that come out of the cage
warrior yeah i mean that's uh
isn't it interesting how in the
beginning it was a little tough or for
me i felt like it was a little tough to
understand his accent and then it got
easier
mm-hmm by the end you're understood
immediately now you have an accent yeah
yeah now i have an accent no you're an
accident but they have different ones
one of them i think is like
really posh you know and one's like i'm
not um oh
me sir you know yeah what one's one's
like street
yeah and jason statham gets shipped for
it because he talks like a street
british accent something called cockney
yeah cockney accent but he he grew up
not cockney so the english call him out
for him
fancy a fig sir fancy an extra fig
is this practicing british she's got 17
types of diff
uh english it's one thing i cannot do i
just can't do a british accent really
you just can't do it
dude even though growing up around i
can't do it with me as i take you on a
guided tour through
all of the accidents so good evening
it's nine o'clock and this is the news
i'm very important
heightened rp is generally only spoken
on film and television now
so you're going to think of nerl card or
the dodger countess
in downton abbey oh gerald i do love you
but you're so terribly terribly poor
now london is the accent that most
people outside of britain can wrestle
a classic lock stocking two smoking
barrels
he was a pro soccer player really before
he was in there
east anglia is a flat bogey kind of
place with a flat foggy kind of
accent i'd love to give you an example
of somebody that comes from there that
speaks like this but they all lose this
accent as soon as they can
stephen fry's from norfolk but he does
she's great
here's the kind of classic kind of give
it a shot brendan
yeah let's do it right now i need to i
need that i need to
don't give me a phrase to say all right
all right
let's give you all right all right mate
let's give you something to say it's
good
all right i know not close though but
australian is british people that
weren't doing good
yeah it is yeah they are is it really
yeah man they were sick of the rain and
[ __ ] bad teeth so they went over
they said you're not doing good you got
to go there
really yeah man yeah let's give let's
give brenda something to say
cheeky bastard i'm knackered that's what
you got to say that means i'm tired yeah
cheeky bastard and careful on the
knackered brother yeah yeah
yeah he's got to be kids
you get a little loose around the end
only the n-word in other cultures yeah
that's true that's true
that's true american m-words he doesn't
say him man but that word is another
culture
it's a loose knackered mate
here's some common british phrases cat
you want to take us through a couple of
these
two impress your mates
let's go brendan no i need to hear
someone
say it in the accent british slang let's
look at that if you don't mind
if we can zoom in on there a cock-up
brilliant hair a lot cheers yeah bugger
off
dude you would be a good british person
chappelle i think
it's cause i watched a lot of uh oasis
videos to be honest
i think that's one of the biggest
reasons i watched a lot of their
interviews
i think they would love chappelle oasis
and cat too
dude uh the british
because i don't think that they have a
lot of vietnamese women there
oh would i be exotic when i go over
there yeah
like a zebra i've never felt more exotic
than when i hang out with you guys
really really i'm not aware that i'm
asian until i'm here
[Laughter]
more theos but he always brings it up
yeah i'm kind of used to it by now
oh wow i can feel exotic yeah i've never
felt exotic in my life because i grew up
around a bunch of asians and a bunch of
mexicans and then i hung out with you
guys and now i'm like
wow asian girl i'm like a [ __ ]
unicorn damn
dang i'm sorry yeah every time i meet
somebody that's different than me i
immediately say they are
you see her every tuesday yeah that's
true it's only once a week though
yeah it'll phase down a little i think
probably in the
third year you make you feel like a
unicorn that's a good thing that's a
good point
it is it's a great thing yeah i wonder
why i do that it's so weird you know i
wonder if i lived there that i would
catch on to the accident like if i
spent the rest of my life there i wonder
if i would catch on you'll pick up on
certain things
not the whole accident yeah i bet you
because you said your mom doesn't have
the accent anymore she's
definitely lost it yeah dude if we got
your aunts to send in the freaking king
in a stinging videos that'd be awesome
i'll get my mom to send him one oh
that's great and i could probably get
somebody else that's in our family
somehow like my cousin's wife or
something or somebody
you know my buddy's cousin or something
send in something that could be fun only
cats crew uh
family submissions wow family episodes
let's get chin's fine ass
[Laughter]
right yeah you don't be funny my parents
if my parents said something that'd be
super funny
that'd be cool so let's talk about
britain man we're supposed to talk about
britain i don't know i feel like we have
been haven't we oh here's a guy right
here he's from britain
cold carter how are we doing good my
name's sean i'm from the north scotland
a place called inverness
if you don't know where that is uh the
loch ness monster stays about three
miles that way
wow wow and cat that's not the loch ness
monster that people are dropping into
your dm's about
so i've got a debate club for you we're
in scotland it's dinner time
do you go for that haggis neeps and
titties here or do you go for that
english bangers and mash
that's haggis turnip and potatoes or
sausage and potatoes
let me know what you think gangang buzz
buzz
i think haggis is like goat liver or
something sheep's pluck
minced onion oatmeal suet spices salt
mixed with stock
that's a hard pass oh and it's encased
in uh animal's stomach
oh crazy as it should be yeah that's
what sausage is in though
that's true yeah so they're a bit
similar i think i'm going argus man
i'm going bang his mash are you yes okay
i love you i always have always have
there we go he's getting it
always happens i'll get it by the end
yeah
ooh those bangers look a little girthy
huh
looks like my dms
this [ __ ] is fire that's what i would
eat yeah yeah or fish and chips that's
you'd eat air fish and chips man that's
it um and he has mash all day for me
beans for breakfast i'm going august man
you know i'm just opening my face up by
the shoreline and just beat a bunch of
just
just toss that in there yeah yeah
um and there's different types of also
accents i know that if they have like if
you're
like real fancy you like talk like this
that's what i'm saying that's uh that
they give uh jason statham [ __ ] because
yeah he
originally had the fancy accent and then
he got to be more like famous as like a
tough guy
he started using the cockney accent
people like dude what are you doing a
spot of tea sir
you know but then they gotta have some
more yeah there you go
okay then he's gonna have it
and then uh but then if you're like that
like if you're like oh can't
my leg fell off sir my leg fell off and
i can't
you know i need something to feed my mom
you know
monsieur rose so fancy roll and that's
more like uh
like yeah you're living in the street
yeah oh i can't i've got a rash on my
box sir
will you scratch my back buddy you
cheeky bastard
you cheeky bastard oh scratch
[Laughter]
yeah it's more sort of a street cap it's
more hood it's a little more thug
yeah okay and the avocado shirt really
helps with it oh thank you very much
it's a nice shirt yeah this is actually
a breakfast
shirt that's from they're from australia
they sent me some stuff they did yeah it
it's only vegetables and fruits on the
[ __ ] no they got something they did
well i got one with a jellyfish yep
they got some good items you should wear
man you know a friend of mine wanted
some licorice i said look little bastard
i'll get you some licorice
yeah that was me it was i appreciate you
sending that man over to my house oh
you're welcome man
yeah you talking about the mvp of this
corn team we talking about postmates
yeah
everybody freaking out postmates said
calm down we got you fam
what you need you need a burrito at two
in the morning yeah you need a sushi
roll at seven a.m
psycho yeah you need a couple gummy
worms at six in the morning bro whatever
you need you need a freaking uh
little cake you need a cake for your
cousin bro it's at 5 p.m
oh you need a monster energy drink from
walgreens we got you 7-eleven we got you
just download postmates on your phone
and get anything you want delivered
within an
hour postmates is giving you delinquents
100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days start your free deliveries
download the app
use the code kats2020 yeah that's code
kats 2020 get what you need get a
gatorade get a um
get a gatorade sweet and salted cashews
get a damn muffin
yeah dog that's 100 free delivery credit
for your first seven days
when you download the post mates app
code kats
2020 anything you need anytime you need
it post mates it
look man i gotta tell you this man and
i've been trying to tell you man
what what is i'm telling you about ship
station bro
we'll make ship happen bro dude i'm
trying here's the thing i keep trying
you hear me knocking yeah ship it bro oh
dude i'm telling you bro i keep trying
to ship stuff to you
and you keep moving to different places
so
it's just getting harder and harder man
thankfully i'm using ship station
it's the fastest easiest most affordable
way
to manage and ship your orders they do
make it super easy ship station makes it
so dang
easy shipstation helps online sellers of
any size get orders out
quickly that's right money on shipping
costs whatever it is dude
amazon you selling that [ __ ] yeah
and ship station they'll
send your [ __ ] yep you might not
like people to get there on time it'll
get there on time if you sell them
through amazon etsy or your own website
ship station brings all the orders into
one simple
interface you can manage it all easily
even from your cell phone
you can and ship station you know they
sort through all the carriers so you
don't have to do that leg work
usb fedex ups even amazon all right and
right now king and sting listeners you
can try ship station free
for 60 days when you use the code kats
make sure your business
is ready for all this man get started at
shipstation.com today
that's right we all know that the uh the
fed the mail system is a complete piece
of [ __ ]
yeah so it's time to take things into
your own hands
literally you can do it on your phone
on the website click on the microphone
at the top of the home page
and type in k-a-t-s that ship station
dot-com then enter offer code k-a-t-s
shipstation.com make ship happen here's
a guy right here from uh
from high street pub ready
yo what is going on guys my name is
lewis i'm coming from
oxford in england and i am outside of
the eagle
and child's pub one of the oldest pubs
in the country now this is where tolkien
wrote a lot of the lord of the rings
books wow and he would tell
the stories to his oxford university
students
and right across the road there we've
got oxford university which is where a
lot of the harry potter films
were filmed so my question to you is are
we saying lord
or harry potter are you going gandolf or
dumbledore
dobby or what is
well done lewis um he also said that pub
is the eagle and child pub a drinking
house where jrr
token uh would write a lot of the lord
of the rings books yeah that's what he
said in the video oh and then read aloud
to his oxford university student sorry
if you said that
yeah that's what he said my bad he's got
you listening
i don't know that's good english yeah
yeah yeah thanks give you an american
accent for us
the eagle and the child it says huh very
i'm not a big uh harry potter fan are
you that's more
i kind of missed that lola rings was
dope too long for my liking though it's
in the theater for a hot
four hours or whatever the [ __ ] it was
question which one do i like the hobbits
and the big feet
yeah ah i like hermione dude
hermione though hermione oh i'll put it
yeah i'll put it in there and then and
then rudy was also a lord of the rings
rudy is a but that's about notre dame
yeah but rudy turned into a hobbit oh he
is in it
are you talking about that emma watts
yeah rudy's in uh lord of the rings
forgot he's in that
uh sean sean austin
shawn aston talks mental health yeah he
was a legend dude and if he did rudy and
then he did dang that
i'm going with that you would think
those boys got paid right but we had one
of the hobbits on the
on my show before and he was saying they
knew it was going to be huge
so when they signed the contracts they
tied them in for like all the
oh and they're like you're only getting
this we know it's going to be big we can
hire anybody
so you you're getting this much every
every movie
so because i was like damn you said you
got that [ __ ] you hobbit money he's like
no i don't
they knew it was going to be big off the
jump oh that's so they signed us to a
low deal
oh that's depressing man
it's just depressing people just taking
advantage of people at every turn you
know
just because they're small hobbits you
know yeah that's ridiculous because
they're small hobbits
there you go i love you i always have
yeah i always have
now i'm gonna say what was the man
asking about which one harry potter or
lord of the rings
well the rings all goddamn day i'm a
grown man i'm switching i'm gonna go
harry potter man
that's fair you know i want to see that
dumbledore that gryffindor
what's that game they play that freeze
tags
dude you would have been a you'd have
been a keeper in quidditch you better
get a
thick broom for me
[Laughter]
dude what about thick broom bite club
our thick boy broom club
here's a fella right here and thank you
for all these submissions man wow a lot
of uh
a lot of cats uh listeners over there
this is some nerds playing real
quidditch oh damn no it ain't oh there
you go yeah
touch and dawn ain't nobody got ain't
nobody got a girlfriend on that team
dude if you're playing quidditch
that that's basically the equivalent
playing larp over here you know
yes look dude i feel like quidditch is
popular over in silicon valley i feel
like i've driven past by google and saw
a lot of workers playing
wow wow they pretend they're flying and
[ __ ] and throw the ball through the it's
a bummer
they used to play smear the queer when i
was growing up yeah also known as rugby
yeah and it was uh and nobody was queer
but everybody got smeared that was the
thing
you came caught that anymore nope and
you probably shouldn't because if
somebody's really gay in the
neighborhood they're like [ __ ]
i'm always hit man yeah i'm getting sick
of this [ __ ] game yeah
just you guys tackle me all the time
because i came out in fourth grade
and that's why they play quidditch now
that's true yeah you can't play red
rover red rover anymore
you remember that no kids can't play any
red rover they can't play dodge ball
there's no kickball dodgeball red rover
red rover red rover i couldn't wait all
them little [ __ ] holding their hands
like this
like red rover red rover send brendan
right over and uh
my thick ass just shoot that 40 yard
dash
vernon's the only one who run over with
somebody on his back like a little guy
on his back
a little salvadorian jockey like a
cannonball in that [ __ ]
can't play that destined to be the wedge
buster oh that's what i did dude but
here was the problem with red rover and
i think it originated as a british game
actually if you'll look that up if you
don't mind nick
um red rover a lot of time you run over
and they would pull their hands up and
clothesline you yo that's the fun of it
but that's when the game ended
yeah when someone got [ __ ] up the
other thing is a lot of people are
blowing out their goddamn
shoulders yeah yeah some little girl who
can't even
hold nothing up anyway and she's blowing
out of you know game is played between
lines of players east and west
um in russia russia the
the game's known as al baba al-bab
alibaba
czech republic didn't say where uh
british bulldog they called the british
bulldog first bulldogs game i thought
that's what you took
so but yeah the worst but that's when
the game went in whenever they should do
red rover red rover
clothesline them we should do a red
rover red rover of grown people a league
yeah well not a league just like for the
show
i don't think i should play that'd be
cool cat
cat somebody's gonna get hurt brendan
maybe
it's gonna be one of us or you have a
great time we all eat orange slices
afterwards
this is one of the things that you
didn't this is one of this will be a
teaching moment because
this is what it's like when the big guy
asks the smaller people to play a game
and you
know that if you play with the big guy
you're going to get hurt right even
though he doesn't he just wants to play
the game you know that's his intentions
yeah he's like i just want to play the
game and we're like no dude we can't
play
boxing because you're 206 pounds even
though you're in the fifth grade
and we are all 85 pounds well i like how
chappelle looks like he's a
little guy oh yeah no man we tiny out
here
but you're 240 pounds doug she felt
moonlights as a little guy
why do you think i got these skinnies on
come on now dude
if we go back over to the uk we got to
bring some females with us
i will say that dude because they really
i think they
they have beautiful women there but
they're not as attractive i don't think
is it there's not a ton of them
no you'll see a woman in there no well
no not a ton
not not ton of attractive ones or them
at all i think you just i think there's
like 70 women i feel like in the uk
slim pickens in london there's some
downtown you know
over there by soho house and that but
their posh is all get out mm-hmm
you know what you got here nick a
british related name game
brendan i hope you're both well i've got
my mask on as you can see this will
definitely stop me from getting
coronavirus anyway i have a
uk themed name game for you and that is
british comedians
well ricky gervais would be number one
right okay
eddie izzard would be number two
and here we are it's okay
it's hard no who's my god
russell howard nice wow
russell brand does he count he's done
stand up
yeah that's a good call i'll give you
that is russell howard a real person
yeah
he's big oh wow i gotta check him out
i'm gonna go with
um oh you got this how about
um a british comedian that's enjoyable
or non-enjoyable would be a
good man like um
how about come on
also known as who's the guy always in a
suit
jimmy carr oh jimmy carr i was going to
say jimmy carr yeah i took a picture
with him he's my mom's favorite jimmy
car's a legend he's a legend
very sweet man to say also that
uh who was the guy that died up in
canada
of cocaine the mayor of toronto
[Music]
rob ford
i don't think so you know rob ford came
to the comedy store one night really
yeah not shocked one of the greatest
things ever but rob four
definitely and then i'm gonna go up on a
limb and say um
i'm trying to think of some of the guys
i even worked over there yeah
that guy right there dude oh wow rob
ford bro who looks like prince harry if
he really fell off man
prince hardly looks like tim dillon's
uncle
you guys know about benny hill benny
hill the preacher
no that's benny hen that's been him
a better name game would have been um
british bands
let's do it dude we
this just shows what we know about our
forefathers dude that's tough
jack [ __ ] and jack shore
are the two things we know about her i
can't believe i found that jimmy carr
jimmy car was great it's a good choice
he's so cool oh there's also a girl
there's a girl katie
um nida no kate
moss no is she british kate moss is huh
there you go what if just anything
british do we even know
basically any uh daily show
correspondent i feel like they were all
british comedians
did we say ricky gervais yeah oh mr bean
uh charlie chaplin was british yep
i think uh who's uh the guy who had the
late night talk show from scotland
craig kilburn ferguson craig kilburn was
espn
and also had a late night show yes
that's right um does a comedian named
soju
who's a comedian um there is a oh who's
this comedian i just worked with
over there we don't know a lot of
british comedians
my brain is just that's what happens
when you get too specific
yep yeah well but thank you britain
for letting us leave and choose one of
the 70 hot girls apparently over there
as well
oh i know it's a couple people though
bexie he's a rapper over there
um alex bowen um
i'm just naming british people winston
churchill you've said him twice now you
okay he's good though don churchill his
brother
little don little dog speaking of
british
oh yeah idris elba also
also corona alumni
oh with the show-and-tell bro dude have
you seen me have you seen the wire
the tv show the wire yeah man i'm
american yeah
he does a really good uh english accent
like
american oh yeah in that show i just
started watching it so oh yeah
oh the wire mm-hmm um it's a great show
well [ __ ] man i gotta open it you know
the office was original
english show oh i have to see i haven't
even seen that version yet nope supposed
to be the best version man i'm just
feeling bad i'm just feeling like i
gotta have seven donations
simon cowell yeah you know uh american
idol originated
in england i haven't done anything for
our forefathers man
dude it's crazy that this whole thing
was your idea too yeah
i was excited dude about just talking
let's hear what this guy's saying maybe
he'll
he'll help us out all right gang hope
everyone is well and that chin is still
alive
i'm just out here drawing the british
crunches out with my pooch
hello i've got a question for you guys
the queen chikinga buddy stinger
my opinion is sting the [ __ ] get a real
job
i wanna know what your thoughts over
actually like that wrinkly
first trap also chapala here's a lot of
interest over in manchester for your
sauce so i hope you're bringing that
sauce out internationally
oh let me know what you guys think gang
gang
chi chi bang
the royal family is weird to me man
they're still doing the damn thing
it's getting weirder it's almost like
become a reality show that they won't
discontinue kind of yeah it's like
season
13 and we're just like come on dude when
this shit's gonna end
and then her son was hanging out with
[ __ ] your boy epstein
really oh yeah big time then did the
interview like a
dumbass oh yeah and it was he looked so
guilty
wait what you don't see any of the songs
dude
you know there's the things you know in
the things you don't blow my mind
and i'm an idiot yeah i'm stupid as well
but i know some of this [ __ ]
it just uh yeah man the
queen i look i think it's a it's a it's
like a tradition you know it's like a
tradition it's like
it's like a a christmas tree it's like
halloween really
the other thing is is uh in this case if
we had sam triple and eddie bravo in
here they tell you they think she's the
richest person on earth
wow really yeah they think she runs
everything but then
there's how old is she 107 or something
there's some tradition that i like
though i feel like if you get rid of all
tradition then
everything's going to be a bit boring
they're like the white kardashians
though they're like the original
kardashians 100
like it's no what what she is what the
royal family is no different than what
we did to the kardashians yeah
they're they're famous for no reason
yeah oh but
but everyone looks up to him everyone
wants to know every detail and
everything
like she's not making any policies or
[ __ ] passing any bills or laws
yeah wow and there's our boy dirt nasty
right there and they offered him one
time
70k to say he hooked up with meghan
markle to say he did yeah and he
wouldn't do it he went
he went to dinner with her and then the
tabloids wanted him to say they
did more after really yeah i wouldn't
have taken that and he wouldn't do it
good for him
legend legend legend and he took her on
a date
you know another legend move she's
pretty smoking married a prince
yeah yep married to prince man so i'm
gonna say
what's this guys he's always talking
about the royal family
i think it's kind of cool yeah i thought
there was a king
and he was like real mean like henry
they like cutting heads on now that's
what we need
yeah get a real king up there you got
right now your boy boris fat
johnson yeah also covet alumni oh yeah i
like
now i like forest man but boris looks a
little bit sometimes like too much like
uh
who's that horse looks like the lewis
capaldi the singer
no but he also looks like the brother of
the who's the thick
chick off of um perfect pitch
rebel wilson looks like rebel wilson's
shitty
brother yeah yes yeah like rib
wilson yeah yeah boris definitely
rebel rebel wilson boris also looks like
louis capaldi's uh
dad you know yeah a little bit and louis
capaldi can [ __ ] sing
oh he can't i've never heard of him oh
how do you [ __ ] sing
oh yeah now i got to look into it yeah
well rebel listening on some weight i'm
talking about old school rebel wilson
i'm talking about wendy's rebel wilson
lewis capaldi looks like every character
from harry potter in one person also
they all mix yeah which is pretty pretty
pretty charming pretty remarkable
talented guy super talented but here's
the thing man what are we talking about
oh king of the singing the queen yeah
here's what we need we need real kings
that are willing to
get a dragon get a castle chop your head
off kill somebody yeah chop your head
off
have a night you know castle where's
where's the big fluffy red velvet
rug yeah if you're going to be a king
play it up yeah dude
too many people are being kings but not
doing [ __ ] yeah take [ __ ] over take
countries over
yeah why is why is pitbull acting more
like a king
than the actual king of england you know
worldwide
or the prince of england and where's the
damn king he died
well [ __ ] you got to get another king
how long has it been since had a king no
wonder they're screwing around over
there
you know it's frustrating it just pisses
me off
because they are the original keepers
man so if they can't even get a king
they're milling around under this female
under this you know she's a charming
woman but
you know unless she's a real savage
grandmother she's outlived her husband
68 years jeeps how old is she
uh she king george was her man huh
yeah so that's the thing man yeah i'm
with you though get a dragon dude
yeah get a [ __ ] 94. damn
and then there's that prince uh queen
elizabeth
she can't stop won't stop it won't stop
wow y'all slept on that queen a little
bit
she sure can go and dog and here's uh
here's one of her kids he's got an
offspring tattoo yeah prince andrew
right here
oh if there's anybody that likes
offspring it's prince andrew hello
this is david from scotland who
unfortunately lives in alabama
let's shoot my shots for uh my wife
hayley
she uh went to the grocery store
november and uh i was just wondering if
you're coming back
[Laughter]
anytime soon uh buzz buzz
giggity giggly or whatever the [ __ ]
wait what he just wanted to shoot his
shot and get his wife back just want to
see
he's shooting a shot because his wife
just dipped out and i'm sorry was he in
alabama he said
yeah that was interesting from scotland
unfortunately now in alabama so
at least we know where the ranking goes
it goes mississippi louisiana alabama
scotland
i respect that dude moving up the charts
scotland hopefully he finds his girl oh
yeah good luck man
yeah i'm sure she'll be back soon
and here we got a fella right here and
he looks a bit posh actually
hey it's david from schneiderlin wales
i've got a king in a stinger whales
castles oh kingdom bro
oh wow that's beautiful i mean it's kind
of shitty looking but yeah
so being welsh i king it there's more
castles per square mile
than anywhere else in the world uh so
yeah let me know
kang gang buzz buzz come recovery
must be the local team um dude king
castles dude get some khaleesi in there
spit out some kids running around the
castle
don't see them these days oh and there i
met you mate right there
oh that's oh yeah that was in london man
did he give you that jacket or something
huh did he give you that jacket no
what are you guys doing he had the uh he
said theo had the tags on so he could
return it
in england smart yeah i'm still planning
on returning it
i gotta mail it back to get it returned
[Laughter]
over here
hey different strokes for different
folks man at least you're saving money
i'm telling you as soon as ross dressed
for less opens back up i'm in there
um i would say what was the man asking
again
king of sting castles are now there's a
kentucky castle can we look that up
there's one castle in america
called the kentucky castle and i stayed
there
oh really i stayed there whenever i was
now have you have you ever gone to uh
medieval times
uh yep that's not a real castle though
brendan yeah but it's the closest thing
we have
and you eat chicken with your hands yeah
you're right good call
you in the movie they're at medieval
times and he goes can i get a diet coke
she goes
dude remedial times hints there was no
diet coke
ace ventura
can i get a knife and fork and she goes
dude there are no knife and forks hence
medieval times he goes
oh but there's diet coke dude i got a
long day
was it cable guy oh that's cable guy
yeah it's cable guy because remember he
plays the character
okay i'd love to be part of this yeah
all right but i can't table guy for sure
and there's the kentucky castle right
there and this castle in kentucky's
interesting
because here's what happened a man was
in love with a woman
built the castle for the woman and then
uh she never came back to him oh wow wow
she didn't see the pictures she she just
wasn't down
because it's a castle usually because
the old saying was build that castle get
that [ __ ]
let's build that castle get that [ __ ]
oh
damn that's aggressive yeah that is very
aggressive brandon well that's the
saying in kentucky i didn't make it up
well that's why you built a goddamn
castle
now i want to see what do you guys think
about the british from being from asian
and
african-american white culture what do
you guys do you guys have thoughts about
the british growing up
what do you mean did you guys have any
like thoughts about it like did you guys
have any
british people to me they're exotic
because i love game of thrones and [ __ ]
like that yeah i love harry potter
so to me like the way people see like
i'm an asian girl i'm like wow that's a
unicorn
wow there's brits you hear that fellas
hey
but you gotta wait till they talk yeah
it's just a white guy to you right
i like white guys though oh but that's
true but you don't know until they
don't know speak really but they
probably walk a bit more like hey
like yeah hey you
probably you gotta get chappelle over
there chappelle we gotta get you
over there what do you think about the
british you already thought about the
bridge oh yeah cause there's a lot of
the punk rock bands that i listened to
slipknot are they british no they're
from iowa des moines i see
no no no no basically corn british they
call them no corn
the who yeah oh yeah huh um then you got
some like
the punk rock like discharge um
exploited gbh um
sex pistols cockney rejects you got a
lot
this guy's got got one for you is that
okay here there's a guy right here
he knows the bands brendan and phil down
here from up north in the uk
i've got i can get it and stink it for
chappelle we've got oasis definitely
maybe
or stone roses gang gangs boss nuts
oh man huh i don't know something they
do
oh that's a very good question with
those people
yeah oh man yeah he hit me with a tough
question
uh i'll probably have to go with uh
oasis definitely made me that's my
favorite album and you got to know who
these people are brendan
yeah no but it's [ __ ] you listen to
nickelback it's chappelle and his
friends dude
yeah these are kind of kids that meet up
in an abandoned walmart
you know and somebody you know drags in
a generator and that you know
plugs in a couple fluorescent lights and
they beat the [ __ ] out of each other oh
you're talking about a rave
paint each other's bodies and stuff yeah
i've seen it it's wicking baby
you ever been in a mosh pit it's salem i
was in one when i was growing
up there was a band called around me
called like deaf kitty or something like
that
it was always an impairment matched with
an animal you know
it was like a blind monkey deaf kitty
you know like shut bats
[Laughter]
yeah yeah wheelchair lemurs you know
it was always something that had to do
with this white shut bats
i don't know a handicap and then a an
animal
you know that's hilarious yeah
um drowned alligators you know
we got a show tonight man my buddy was a
manager of the subway and it's cl
yeah after hours bro be it be there
you have you gone to a rave yeah i've
been to some not for me man
yeah all night no [ __ ] no and that's a
british thing i think raves aren't they
where did ray start today
really because bisping used to be a damn
dj
they also got hooligans out there could
also be something fun we could partake
in
oh yeah go to go to one of the premier
league games and join the hooligans and
[ __ ] some people up
right there america they call it
protesting
if you also know it's hardcore by early
period uk
acid movement late 80s
go back one page nick to just the
beginning of oh just the beginning
okay what does it say the uk right at
the top anything
it said it started with the 80s with the
uk acid movement oh wow there you go
you're right so people doing acid
that's a heavy drug wasn't an acid bath
and that's it
is that it no we got a guy right here
another debate club theo vaughn brandon
sharp
coming who's from uh northeast of
scotland
rural scotland i've got a debate called
boys
uh scotland or ireland
scotland we've got uh glasgow haggis
william wallace lewis capaldi
um weskey is originally from scotland
believe it or not oh wow there you go
we've got celts we've got bagpipes we've
got loch ness monster
um andrew schultz's mum is from glasgow
originally wow okay ireland
they've got dublin
leprechauns conor mcgregor
that's pretty much it andrew the fake
irishman santino
he's not from ireland he claims he is
he's not
his last name santino i have nuclear
weight thinks he's
buzz theo thank you so much for coming
to glasgow
a few months ago almost a year ago maybe
um no one ever no one else ever comes up
here so i
will we all appreciate that so much um
[Music]
brenda sharp i know you're planning on
coming up here
i appreciate that as well gang gang buzz
boss
keep doing for your dean and yeah
cool i've got a little romantic guy
i can't think enough here's my gift yeah
i know i thought he was going down
[Laughter]
oh yeah man i love glasgow man i love
scotland man this is so
tough dude i've never been i've only
been to i'm gonna be biased i've only
been to dublin it's the greatest place
i've ever been
wow just because i've never been to
scotland
that's fair and this gives me an out
because since he chose ireland i can
choose scotland boom win win all the way
around
yeah yeah good submission mates yeah
yeah we always loved you chin what do
you think about britain when you guys
hear about it
i always think sophistication smart
whenever i hear people talk with that
british accent oh yeah yeah
fancy jim went out there with me just
good out there so i'm i'm also
ireland by far one of the best places on
earth yeah that's great
you shouldn't try to get a neck hat yeah
that's how much i loved it i was gonna
get a neck tattoo though damn
yeah would y'all get tattooed
in ireland in dublin i'm not sure i
forgot the tattoo artist's name but
there's one of our channel got it she
didn't try to get on his neck but
homeboy wouldn't do it yeah
still bummed about that damn he was
looking out for you
well i would be happy with it so
yeah yeah well cheers mate
cheers cheers man cheers cheers thank
you for the submissions have a great
time
good on you man good on you we did it
first uh country themed episode
yeah what should we do next let the fans
vote i'm assuming australia would be a
banger i think i think australia we
could do australia maybe can you lead us
out with a different the british tune or
something nick that is sex person no
they're
their favorite thing sweet caroline man
oh yeah which is can we play that though
probably not wait sweet by neil diamond
with darren too i love sweet carolina
are you saying it darren till
i don't know diamond is saying it but
dude darren's hail if you notice
whenever he's it always looks like he's
trying to catch a baby that's falling
off a building you notice that
he always has that just that look at the
movement like where's it gonna fall you
know
like hit it nick
shout out till man shout out liverpool
stroud
sheffield essex manchester chester
shout chelsea this is a sound alike so
this works we can't get
we can't get ding for this can we nick i
don't think so
we probably can what's the guy doing
karaoke
well this is a sad version and this is a
senior citizen's home i love it
i think it's a chinese korean barbecue
yeah this is great bro
it's a chinese
[Laughter]
watch them kill it
we need to meet some uh black chinese
guys that's what we need we do there's
black and asians
yeah let's meet a white indian guy but
i'm talking black chinese
that's rarely done i'm talking about
black and ease yeah we'll put an ad
out okay touching me
oh somebody's gonna have a stroke
for some reason super british so good
so good so good ricky hatton came out to
this
against floyd mayweather he did tyson
fury came after this daryn till
tom ford kate spade
are there any female british fighters
where them [ __ ] at
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying i don't know
anything because if you go there a lot
of these ladies look like they've
gone a couple rounds with a freaking
mirror you know
they look like they bite you oh yeah
dude i gotta pee so bad
all right man gang gang bruh
love y'all love you guys good on you
[Music]
britton
[Music]
reaching out
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hello
[Music]
thank you